this week we are partnered with
hellofresh and Rocket money more on them
after the
[Music]
reaction yo citizens of the reject
Nation we have made it to episode three
of hasb been Hotel I just changed into a
sweater we were watching this moments
after episode two Roxy went to the
bathroom she had some crackers good make
sure you tell them I went to the
bathroom if you don't tell them how will
they watch the rest I believe in
authenticity and open communication I do
keep eating crack
yeah before the show then the whole show
I'm like this yeah me too I got some in
my mouth as well hey what do you guys
think of hasman Hotel subscribe and
click that Bell to get notified when our
reaction for four is up here on the
channel leave a like while you're at it
too thank you to prepper I think bring
down these highlights it's episode three
I'm in the middle of this intro Jesus
woman you're right hey I got a got a
quick question for
you no when you're right you're right
yes it's episode three but it's like the
fourth one I just didn't want them to
get confused they won't be and uh full
length Reaction watch a longer you see
with your own copy Pass
Hotel super sexy rejects our patreon
page thank you to all have joined I'm
assuming you have I can see into the
future cover several things over there
exclusive has watch long included I'm
ready you ready let's get this show out
the road y ready for this I like the
husband husband I like the husband
h
[Music]
looks
perfect I am so excited that sir penus
is staying at the hotel this is more
than a warm welcome penus was just
trying to take over the city with his
weird steampunk [__] a few days ago
I haven't seen him try to pull any of
that here what's the passage of time
here hello purple female my new
invention was it a dude I know last
episode had her and a guy looking
forward to shooting the other residents
why everyone is being too nice obviously
it must be a
lie they are planning to kill me but
when how I must be prepared cuz he's
never had love before I get your bad
thank you for your business enjoy your
Carmine purchase as in Carmela Carmine
you are buying parts from an Overlord
Carmine ultimate Overlord name she's the
top weapons dealer in Hell okay well
that stops right now not to be sexist
but there too many women in Hell there's
not that many evil women it's an
objective fact first you get female
representation now you're complaining
about the female representation yep you
have to trust us but I don't why don't
we focus on that for today's activities
no more building weapons no more
plotting against other guests and you
need to get rid of these
things egg egg and eggy not my little
egg boys they do my evil bidding for me
do you want to stay here and redeem
yourself yes yes then no more eggs all
right Eggies a he's really just so soft
no don't resist this is how it has to be
so
theatrical oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
god oh ew oh no I'm in the middle of
breakfast
penis's eggs are all over the place and
I need you to get rid of them what does
a hell deer taste like well in that case
I'd be delighted to humanely that's a
lot less hot but I suppose I can take
care of that on my outing today I'm
obsessed with Alistair and the quality
of his voice is just crazy cool we think
that this group could really benefit
from trust exercis
excises trust exercises are hard let's
get started Charlie AC actually I
thought maybe you could take the lead on
this one oh boy I trust everyone so
maybe you'd know better about how to
build it properly I trust everyone so
you know how to build
it but who does she trust outside of
Charlie but well she's got to learn
starting with trust Falls each of you
are going to share something vulnerable
with the group about yourself and then
fall backwards while the rest of the
group catches you got it that is a hard
hard to watch Harley all right get on up
here
I she going to hit the ground I love you
guys no no no she'll be caught really
love
you
gotcha Angel why don't you go next fine
this time everyone needs to catch him
okay unless you want me to hurt you
incentive I love to suck I swear if you
say popsicles you sicko I also love
popsicles
recently hey but you know to they all
CAU I'm dropped
them I don't want to live without my
minions nobody catch me damn it that's
great sometimes I kill mother bugs in
front of their children is a warning to
others oh
God yay
pain pain oh my God I don't know this is
really working the way we hoped I got
this okay I'll figure something out
Charlie having a trust exercise with her
friend are you're not getting a
relationship Vibes still no not yet can
I touch your staff thing are those your
ears or is it your hair I can't
tell how fa this day oh my God greetings
vestial W holy [__] the weather nothing
become this fine day who looks like we
might have some acid rain this
afternoon oh I just took a well- earned
sabatical nothing serious though it's
fun to keep everyone on their toes now
he's got a master plan rol by far to
assume the workings of your mind Alister
thou been not since thy manifested in
this realm feels truly ancient now stay
here and guard the front until I return
this guy really feels like straight out
of some type of actual like evil lore
like the way he's portrayed he's not
portrayed in a comedic way Frank is up
there we have
names good
henchmen High
Society yeah what is the societal
breakdown in hell I'm interested this is
true how do you get higher in class like
what is the strongest commodity how do
you gain power this year's extermination
was bual we have assessed that about 16%
of the population was lost 16 twice as
quickly I think it prudent we it's
giving leftovers kisses darling nice of
you to join us velvet will your
colleagues be joining no they have
better [__] to do than to listen to an
old windbag who thinks she's tough [__]
I'm here to represent oh gosh you guys
aren't going to succeed with this why
cuz they're women
no that wasn't what I was really
thinking where did you get this we found
it during extermination day if these
holy rollers can be killed the game has
changed can take the fight to
them I would not do that if it be true
thee and my colleagues desire to war
with such me proof Thou Art far more
foolish than I be thought yeah that
would not do that it's a deading
Exorcist you going blind old man they
planted him mayhaps was not by a demon's
hand at all if we rush to war without
knowing might they Purge all of hell for
deing and Uprising I love the way his
dialogue is heard yeah that was planted
saw so grandpa is tooy to fight so I
guess there's no point oh what's the mat
of fossil to scile to make a real power
grab you better show some resp fact wow
no one speaks zest that
way oh my goodness you expect us to sit
back and take your insent bra
display love how classical this was
whoa atude two
genres okay awesome cuz no one could
respect I want her outfit so bad I have
her hair my
god
[Music]
without like how you learn who the
characters are via the songs oops I
strike a
nerve Angel it's like Epic Rap Battles
your wrinkled face was turning red and
why are you avoiding War that's what the
guns you sell are for yeah one thing I'm
to
suspect Angel's head you have
disclosure what does she know reminds me
of Epic Rap Battles of History the
characters are so well flushed out but
they're so well like attuned in the do
in the lyrics
[Music]
Mother that's interesting what you
little egg creature I have a job for you
follow
them he's like Alice in Wonderland he's
like the he's like the Mad Hatter no no
the eggs no activity requires
more no bond stronger than those formed
through Bond hey it's a fair point I
mean you might need like radical
unconventional methods to get this to
work
though you know I I don't hate
this I'm ready to punish some bad
boys okay hello there hi it's like a
Medusa head can't believe I let you drag
us here angel it's no big deal just need
to teach them the way I was taught this
is how you learn to trust
people there is nothing stronger than
the trust between comrades and arms
buckle up buttercups because today you
boys become men oh boy wait I can't
fight without my minions are going to
survive together and you are going to
make this hotel
work oh there's totally Vibes between
them they're both gay aren't they the
women yeah there are other ways it just
takes time time we don't have how many
times will we have to watch your people
be killed before we make Headway I took
charge today and it all went sideways
I'm supposed to make your dreams reality
I'm supposed to protect you a I love
them fgy you're not you're not if I
can't help you what's the point of me
whoa her whole identity is in there was
she created I don't think she's created
I think she just gets her whole identity
and protecting her she gets her purpose
from that yeah I don't know though like
maybe Lilith hired her or something like
maybe she's incentivized or something I
don't know usually your instincts are
right about these things I don't know I
did what I had to
do I am not disgusted got sing this what
whats on your soul friend this going to
be like a serious
song sh the that's what she
said Angel why not your strength
known was I don't think it was it I
didn't think but that I would keep blood
off my face but when that thing attacked
oh [__] I had to she think she killed it
and maybe really they killed
it I don't
[Music]
know suppress the hope that they would
have a chance to win the
war oh nice this is like a rock opera
this this is awesome ballad
[Music]
build imagine going to hell and having
kids that then meet you in hell you'd be
so bummed they ended up in hell but
stoked oh yeah yeah cuz they're with
[Music]
you place and it felt so good to be
understood
that's all people want
[Music]
really a great
line just think about how I would do
cosplay her like I put the red tape over
my hair yeah you mess up your hair for
the sake of Cosplay worth
[Music]
it I love how this is turned into a duet
over two very different things but it's
all in the Name of Love the old guy was
a you're not yourself you're the one
that killed the Angel and the she was
whatever it takes screw your patient
let's keep this between us you got it
boss super Mad
Hatter I'm I'm sorry I got so crazy
today it's okay no I'm sorry no you're
Charlie you're not
sorry that's why you show up to the
videos
guys comedic genius look what your
exercise did for them look they're
getting along the abondon with the
dismembered arm yes that was
particularly
unpleasant I like that part at least you
can take a beaten like a champ you did a
okay little kid you got respect now
thank you for pulling me out of
there I like the change they did with
this character a lot the snake one yeah
cuz he was kind of just generic before
made something really interesting how
was your day with aliser my minions I
went to this meeting and there was a
knife lady an old guy that's nice and
the knife lady killed an angel that took
all of two seconds
oh I'm so sure and maybe you'll meet
martians tomorrow but now it's time for
oh my God you think it's going to click
in a second oh ah yeah I'll end on that
nope oh no way they subverted our
expectations thank you to America's
number one meal kid hellofresh for
partnering with us it's always great to
partner people whose Services you
actually use because as someone like me
who's always juggling a pack schedule
between filming and editing finding time
for healthy eating can be a challenge
that's where hellofresh has been a game
changer for my life with hellofresh I
get farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients
and delicious recipes delivered right to
my doorsteps so I don't have to step
outside it's revolutionized my home
cooking experience making it not just
easy but super enjoyable and affordable
keyw I recently tried their delicious
barbecue pineapple flat RADS and their
zucchini pomodora Panet baked both were
mouthwatering delicious and fit
perfectly with my pescatarian lifestyle
pescatarian M sounds fancy and asking my
friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a
meat eater again people I know I've
really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken palard I think is how you
pronounce it in the fuo chicken fajo
tacos regardless hellofresh menu has
something for everyone but of course
it's not just about the food it's about
saving time too not having a wait in
line at a grocery store even self
checkouts on fast enough these days the
convenience of having everything
delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with her
quick and easy meals like 15-minute
recipes spending less time in the
kitchen and more time doing what I love
which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to
support the channel and also support you
know having a new lifestyle healthy
affordable lifestyle in the year 2024 go
to hellofresh.com rejects free and use
code rejects free for free breakfast for
life you heard that right one breakfast
item per box while the subscription is
active free breakfast for life for
hellofresh.com reject free use promo
code reject free try it out and let me
know your favorite is stay healthy and
let's keep enjoying those movies and
shows all right reject Nation let's get
real for a moment running this channel
is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for
the channel and my personal life can be
overwhelming that's where rocket money
has been a financial Lifesaver for me
even before I ever partnered up with
them like I said I've been very
fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a
win-win for him walk but it can be a
win-win for you too cuz there's a reason
I use them rocket money is a personal
finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and
crafting a budget that fits your
specific lifestyle for someone like me
who can easily lose track of expenses
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye openening to see where I
was overspending stuff I don't use that
I kept paying for especially apps man I
was way too many apps rocket money does
a heavy lifting by analyzing your
spending then customizes notifications
to help you stay within your budget
goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly
subscriptions too so many free trials
I've signed up for that I forgot to you
know get rid of before the free trial
was done making it super easy to cancel
the ones you don't use couple of clicks
and you're putting money back in your
pocket telling you have you ever found
hidden subscriptions or pay for services
you forgot about because Rocky money is
a huge asset in helping to uncover those
and even negotiated some of my bills
down to like 20% so if you're ready to
take control of your finances and
there's no better time than now because
it is the beginning of the year check
out rocket money and see how much you
could be saving stop wasting money on
things you do not use so to help support
the channel and help support your wallet
visit rocket money / rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident
they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank
account will thank you they are lovers
confirmed who Charlie and what's the
friend's name bestie is that her name B
oh vaggy vaggie Vagabond yeah it should
be the easiest name to remember like
pull but then you got to like kind of
work the brain like oh yeah vaggy yeah
yeah no they are they really do give me
and I don't mean like they stole it
because obviously like it's they've made
it their own but it's really truly
Harley Quinn and Poison Ivy and I want
them to get it on like Donkey Kong yeah
me too I want to see it on camera I want
the power Dynamic could be difficult we
going to see how they make it work
because clearly poison ivy is obsessed
with Harley Quinn and the scenario but I
just want to make sure that Harley has
the same kind of feelings for poison iy
yeah I don't get the sense that Charlie
actually has the feelings that's the
part I don't feel it from Charlie the
way that I do from Vagabond well is it
vagi or vaggie vaggie vaggy hard G yeah
yeah yeah cuz sometimes I think they're
using the homophobic slur and I'm like
that's not what they're
saying with an F oh yeah was like just
you're just such a good person you
couldn't think of it yeah well it was
cuz the why at the end like I I don't
hear it like that yeah yeah no yeah I I
know I get what you're saying now it's
just like I have to hear the
V hear the V yeah yeah I mean um can you
hear the V with him uhhuh I think that I
don't know where it's going to end up
with them but in terms of like the
immediate Journey at hand um I like how
it what they've really been evolving to
in other ways like we saw it with me
we've been seeing it with media of the
political intricacies and then with this
episode you're seeing more of like this
high class secret society the ones who
really control secret society secret
society secret society within hell like
with the secret meetings and stuff I'm
super curious how each of those gets
invited to the meeting because we do
like it's old money and it's new money
in terms of we see that guy put some
respect on his name tall dude and then
the girl that was standing up for him
but then the girl that I want to be
who's got pigtails she's like uh yo I am
new school and this is crazy what's her
name with the v no idea Valencia Valerie
vaggie no not her pigtails vager V I
think it's just V just V she's like uh
no I disagree and we should go start a
war and is that rash I don't know but it
is it's interesting see you everybody at
the table who's that dinosaur person
need to know more about the dinosaur
yeah they have created a whole world I
give a crap about about every single
character I want to know how we got here
I'm still thinking about where Lilith is
I'm still thinking about how why uh our
our dude the devil dude devil radio dude
is was gone for seven years now people
are just like well we're welcoming you
back uh but he was questioned on that by
he was but then she was like it was fine
demonic entity guy yep what I love too
with this one is they had like such a
variety of music I said It reminds me of
EP epic rap battles of history have you
ever seen them yeah because what what's
so cool about that is like yeah they
write the RS and they verse each other
but they're also I yeah but I haven't
you haven't Epic Rap Battles of History
haven't heard them no yes to heard of it
no to seen it it is and I said yeah
really quick but then I just wanted you
to know that was a lie I appreciate your
honesty yeah no seriously and you don't
get that too often in life anymore
people just kind of lie especially on
camera people feel like they got to know
everything but sometimes I don't [__]
ain't no [__] but hos and tricks you
have to bring down the rest of your sex
in order to you know oh no no [__] is
not um specific to women is it no not
pry sure when I say it I only use it as
a derogatory term towards women oh but
you can't say vaggy I have a hard time
where it's going to come across
differently when I say it out uhhuh
uhhuh uhhuh uhhuh but the music you were
liking cuz rap battles epic rap battles
of history so what they'll do is they'll
take like two characters you know like
Indiana Jones versus uh Han Solo and
then they write raps versus it's just
like a rap battle but it's within the
characters of them with the same actor
no no I usually get different actors and
oh you just picked the same actor they
just took two the same characters I mean
two different characters who happen to
be played by the same actor just slow it
down all right so they verse each other
and and what they'll so like Indiana
Jones will like um you know dish out
insults about Han Solo and Han Solo it's
like a rap battle so it's very character
driven at the same time and I think
that's what they do a lot with with
these kind kind of Duets not a duet but
when they're especially when they like
this slice of genre where one starts off
kind of like a classical Opera ballad
and then the other one goes into like
hip-hop or something of that nature when
they're I love the verses of that and
then you get something that is like a
duet where you have people on two very
different sides of town coming from
different angles but also rooted in a
similar emotion of love and protection
uh with characters who haven't even
interacted with each other but you get
to see the similarities here and that's
the kind of thing that could could lead
to a reform like I I really feel like
they're building into something that's I
think it's really easy to look at the
show and just see you know the like oh
look how Vivid the colors are and how
expression of this is and that's all
grandiose there there always seems like
there's something a little bit deeper
underneath the surface here because we
have gotten a lot more political in the
way the world is being built out and
then you even get a character who I
don't know what that character is the
one who everyone feared when they were
taking the cell phone photos and stuff
and Guy yeah tall creepy guy like all of
his lines were serious everyone every
line he had just truly seemed like a guy
from a different time period and and the
way he spoke with such uh the deboner
qualities all this elegancy and you're
using some really good vocab words right
now Greg really oh no I lost it
oh you like the tall guy yeah I like big
big guy big dude big big big big big dra
guy yeah I lo uh I loved uh the way he
was flushed out and I think they' done
an excellent job there and
somehow what I what I think is really
clever about what the show has done is
they have I'm doing totally this symbol
here lizard people what about lizard
people don't say too what your's gonna
call the lizard people this calls lizard
people maybe I thought this is the Kanye
West diamonds in the sky oh no is that
on it I like to are you threatening me
Jewish
friend have you heard of
Connie yeah once or
twice I don't know what his opinion is
about Jews but this is what he do
okay but uh
um are they doing this in two batches
for before what were we saying what was
I saying before the Kanye was you were
so off the tracks I don't even know
where you were going with the tall was
on the tracks and then you started
saying lizard people because you told
said this is what I'm doing with my
hands I know I got distracted by
myself yeah U but you were saying you
like the tall guy and people were scared
of him anyway good episode yeah I guess
you didn't love it I just felt like I
had a point I want to get out all right
well think about it take a second matter
of fact you should take
four one
two
three yes I remember my God I got it
it's that the fact that they have this
storyline where you're going to the
other side of town with
Alistair and you're you're learning
about oh they're they're keeping this
really hidden like At first it's a
mystery of who killed this Exorcist but
then they want to suppress that because
if they know there's a chance of winning
not even a chance of winning they the
people in charge really think there's no
chance of winning and they don't want to
give people hope at a chance of like
some type of Revolution right and that's
a completely bigger story and and a
whole other area to explore then you
keep cutting back to the hasbin hotel
immediacy of that which is a little bit
more comical but that's where you get
something that is more emotional and I
like that the thing that tethers them
together is the thing that is the
countdown to the extermination um is
that what they're calling it The purging
the cleansing whatever is is the
countdown to it but they're they feel
like completely different types of
stories yet the marriage of them is so
well done yeah like you're saying
there's a lot of different layers to it
like do the people in charge in Hell not
want people to know that she was capable
of kill an angel because they don't
think they're capable of winning the war
and they don't want their people to get
hurt or is it because they don't want to
give them the Hope or is it because
they're scared that they're going to do
an uprising too many of them are going
to die and then hell is going to be
weaker or they're scared that some of
them are actually going to escape and
then they'll less con constituents in
hell like there there's got to be all
different motives and because of
Alistair I still not knowing what's up
with him I feel like he's going to be
the big twist of the season I I and I I
don't fully trust him we have to know
what is he doing here what does he know
and now he has this information from
eggy so what's he going to do with that
who's he report back to is it
Lilith yeah I think you're right I think
it's lth well let's see what episode
four reveals to us guys for schore and
has been a hotel ago this is why Roxy is
a TV girl she's here provide good
commentary like that um leave your
thoughts down below about uh if you were
to send someone that you know in in your
personal life to Hell who would it be uh
that's my YouTube question for the day
and tag them tag them Time the video all
right well uh we'll see you guys for
episode four
Maria Hammond Maria it was your birthday
recently so wanted to say happy birthday
to you and for
2024 we got to send you a gift yes we do
what are we realistically going to send
her a puppy
no uh your responsibility we don't want
it we found it on the street take it
please take it is it alive we just
packed it in a UPS box taped it sh yes
like fragile there's a bowl of water
hopefully it doesn't fall over spill all
over this thing um oh goodness we could
get her something commemorative we can
name a star after
her that's not a bad gift John you know
I'm saying like I mean of all things to
commemorate your cost more than what she
pays every month for undoubtedly so you
know what will have to financial if you
can increase your pledge so we can get
you this St
yeah I think you only have to pay for it
once so like you know you don't
subscribe to the star unfair see what
you did you wanted the star and now you
just took advantage of us may it seem
like you forging and now we got to give
you a gift once you fully paid off your
gift
thanks but seriously app we got we got
to get you some it I'm already thinking
about it but no thank you for being such
an amazing human being here's to another
78 more years of minimum enjoying not
saying you're 78 I was just throwing out
a random number just to stay alive for
at least lives
past like 80 on average right yeah it's
like the going rate right now what is
the average person Maria let's make this
really fun for your birthday what is the
average mortality yeah John type it in
what is the average mortality rate what
is the
a average I really don't know
how3
okay so we're getting close
7316 years according to quora okay the
average life expectancy in the world
right now hope I hope you be the first
person what is the oldest person I've
ever lived who's the old 70 actually 70
years for men and 75 for women yeah okay
they got less problems that's why that's
right much more relaxed life what is the
oldest
person how old is the current
oldest the
world oh you can beat them all right
Maria they're only 116 years old they
live in Spain their name's also Maria oh
my God holy [__] it was meant to be
Maria you got to be the new dominant
extended life Maria yes if you could
just make it to 118 I think you got a
good amount of distance between the next
runner up so we're going to do whatever
it takes that's what we're going to do
we're going to send you an IV we're
going to get you cry Frozen we're going
to uh send you some vitamins we're going
to get you some uh oh oh that whatever
it takes to get you that baby blood
stuff that people are always freaking
out about yeah people talk about quality
of life not quantity hell with that I
don't care how miserable you get I don't
care if you develop some debilitating
disease over the next couple years and
you're just like oh my God just put me
out of my misery no we will trap you
we're going to get you that hydrochrome
even if we have to just keep your head
alive in a tank like Futurama we will do
it to make sure you make it to that's
your gift that's your GI put your head
over here is not letting you die yes
your gift is forced
immortality it's good so yeah happy
birthday Maria love you love you you've
been an absolute gem in our lives and
you you know damn well that we know that
so thank you my
[Music]
dear